OTHER POWERFUL WORLD LEADERS IS
A HUGE WIN FOR VLADAMIR PUTIN NO
MATTER WHAT WAS DISCUSSED.
>> DAVE DID GERGEN, I KNOW YOU'A
BELIEVER IN DIPLOMACY.
THE FACT THIS WENT MORE THAN TWO
HOURS, THE WHITE HOUSE MAY HAVE
BEEN SETTING A LOW BAR HERE,
SAYING THE MEETING WAS ONLY
SUPPOSED TO LAST 35 MINUTES, BUT
TWO HOURS IS A LONG TIME,
PERIOD.
>> WE SHOULD WELCOME THE FACT
THAT THEY SPENT TWO HOURS AND 15
MINUTES TOGETHER AND NOT THE 30
MINUTES THAT WAS ON THE
SCHEDULE, BECAUSE IT DOES MEAN
THEY WENT DEEPER, THEY WERE MORE
SERIOUS, THEY'VE ENGAGED MORE.
LISTEN, EARLIER IN THE WEEK,
DAVID SANGER, WORLD CLASS
JOURNALIST, WROTE A PIECE IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RECALLING
HOW JOHN KENNEDY WENT TO HIS
FIRST RUSSIAN LEADER KHRUSHCHEV.
HE WAS A BULLY, AND HE WALKED
OVER KENNEDY.
IT WAS A MESS.
AND FROM THAT, AS YOU SAID
EARLIER IN THE SHOW, CKENNEDY
SAID WAY BACK THEN WE HAVE TO
SHOW KHRUSHCHEV HOW SERIOUS WE
ARE, MAYBE VIETNAM IS THE PLACE
TO START.
TRUMP DIDN'T DO THAT TODAY.
HE DIDN'T CRUMPLE IN FRONT OF
PUTIN.
AND PUTIN DIDN'T BULLY HIM INTO
A CORNER.
THERE WERE NO APPARENT SHOUTS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE, YOU KNOW,
WHEN THE PRESIDENT GETS
SOMETHING -- DOES SOMETHING
BETTER THAN EXPECTED, WE SHOULD
SAY SO.
BUT I DO THINK WHAT HAS BEEN --
ALL OF OUR FOCUS ON PUTIN, ONE
THING THAT'S BEING OVERSHADOWED
IS THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE
SEEN A PRESIDENT COMING TO A G20